one two three four
one way or another I'm gonna find you
I'm gonna get you get to get you get you
one way for another I'm gonna win ya I'm
gonna change
the Sanderson sisters are back I bet
you're looking for the stage
and they're taking Center Stage
yeah it's been almost 30 years since
Bette Midler Sarah Jessica Parker and
Kathy najimi brought the Sanderson
sisters to life in Hocus Pocus
tell me a dumpling
what is the yeah
1993. sisters
we have been gone 300 years
how time flies huh when you're dead
now they're back reprising their iconic
characters for Hocus Pocus 2.
0
[Music]
and they're giving us all those
throwback Fields including some epic
musical moments
who are they performing for you
but it wouldn't be Hocus Pocus without
the sisters putting a spell on the town
through song and that's exactly what
they do to Blondie's hit track one way
or another
I'm gonna see ya
[Music]
and that scene is giving off major 1993
OG Hocus Pocus vibes
maybe I'll be back E.T was with Kathy
Sarah Jessica and bet at the premiere
for The Flick and they opened up about
slipping back into character decades
later let's give it up for hey Winnie
what do you call yourselves
The Originals finding Mary again I
didn't even think about it she's just in
there
so she's in there and I just start the
scene and out she comes and she has all
the power and control I'm just the being
that she inhabits she sometimes it's not
much it's like so when do you like me
best that's pretty much it sorry Winnie
sorry
my group isn't misbehaving
I'm surfing cowabunga
being on the set with bed and Kathy
every day singing and flying trying to
recall and remember what we did and why
the easy part is just
being you know back among this group and
getting to tell another chapter in the
story and working with the great musical
department and getting to sing again and
flying we must fly
on what
just like my old one
what about us there's only one that's
the Beatles find something anything we
must fly you love to fly you're even up
in the air reading your newspapers
during the break yeah yeah yeah I did
that on the first movie this movie The
Flying the um the technology has changed
the engineering and the way they fly
people now and your device that you're
flying on it's yes I'm on a Swiffer and
um Kathy's on a Roomba I mean and Beck
got the broom yeah totally 2022 yeah she
was screaming at us you know get a room
get a broom and there was only one room
so she got it yeah that's winning not
bad
foreign
[Music]
was so anxious to make this work and I
think it does I I'm very proud of it
[Music]